2 3 4 2 3 4 2 pourquoi oui car olalala
habits très chers amis si vous saviez au
jeu là mais tout écraser lomé mais que
se passe-t-il monsieur dix neuf vous
avez fait du bricolage mais non mon cher
françois pire que cela
sescoi c'est là mais dans une forte
chers amis là bas car je me serais assis
sur votre main saumon apercevoir mais
non ma vo casimir c'est pire que cela
encore
alors là je ne vois qu'une explication
une explication touchant nous avait
serré la main de mademoiselle futé c'est
cela même elle était arrivée par le
dernier bateau je marchais
tranquillement sur le plan quelque peu
perdu dans mes pensées
quand tout à coup elle descend de la
passerelle
elle me dit tyran nous la main
instinctivement je tends ma fine mains
d'artistes et voilà à l'assise est ce
que je souris magie non sans peine je
retiens beaucoup monsieur du soir
j'aime être à ma place qu'à l'avant et
bien ne t'en fais pas casimir elle m'a
dit qu'elle allait venir vous voir ici
même mais c'était convaincante
et bien moi je ferme mon coeur et je
rentre chez moi et moi je vais je mettre
nommé ballon dans ton cas ce que julie
comme ça je pourrais partir tu vivais
moi je vais aliments fermé à double tour
dans mon grenier
trop tard près son calme après tout à
part c'est pauline un peu trop
vigoureuse mademoiselle fuite est une
personne très sympathique chivet bonjour
il ajouté bonjour françois s'est rendu
l'âme
allez vous faire mourir j'ai excellent
mais c'est bon j'ai compris je lis
feront de même avec hummer aussi calme
vous avez dû faire une très belle
traversée non home j'espère au moins que
mon petit hérisson nougatine d'antan
fusée de serrer la main c'est gentil
[ __ ] ce que j'ai moi mais ça me gratte
que ça mon grade partout on m'a très
bien c'est pas pourquoi vous me détestez
au point de refuser de me serrer la main
mais je peux vous dire que vous vous
faites beaucoup de fun jt nimubona je
tiens je vous prie je préfère ignorer de
quelle injustice je suis victime et vous
n'allez pas croire des choses quand il
était petit et simplement vous me fait
beaucoup de peine que du mien
moi qui l'inventé tant d'affection alors
il est inutile de s'attendrir eh bien je
vais vous laisser je vais retourner à
mes travaux il est inutile je pense de
vous proposer de vous serrer la main aux
dieux
[Musique]
parfois mademoiselle futé elle a cru que
nous refusions de de lui serrer la main
parce que nous la détestons mais c'est
vraiment trop bête mais oui on est un
petit peu exaspérant mais pas plus comme
un seuil du snob
ab je te remercie casimir très gentil
pour moi mais si c'est un gentil ge
je voudrais dire qu'on peut à la fois
être bête est sympa quelqu'un kazemi est
une façon d'expliquer les choses qui est
particulièrement délicat lolo le centre
y écouter il en est pas dispute
il ne faut pas laisser mademoiselle
chutait croire que nous la détestons
alors j'ai un plan monsieur du snob vous
courrez derrière mademoiselle futé et
vous nous les ramener ici le plus vite
possible
pour l'instant la julie casimir et moi
nous nous entraînons à donner de
vigoureuse poignée de mains très bien
trash avant soit jvg cause je vous
ramène aux insultes et je vous le
promets et bien il ne nous reste plus
qu'à commencer l'entraînement qui est
volontaire j'ai moi moi je parle de te
faire mal dans l'eau un peu de courage
casimir donne moi ta main regarde c'est
très facile il suffit d'engager sa main
bien à fond dans celle de l'autre comme
ça et de serrer très fort juste en même
temps que lui comme ça mais casimir il
faut serrer en même temps et on
recommence applique toi 2 3
on recommence 2 3 cette fois c'est moi
qui ai pas sérieux bon allez on
recommence le temps moi je voudrais bien
exercer un peu aussi mais c'est vrai bah
oui alors attention vous êtes prêt à
vous signale un deux trois non je lis il
faut serrer en même temps et c'est pas
grave on recommence 1 2 3
casimir casimir pompiers au pied casimir
pompiers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on me voici mes amis du jeune homme m'a
tout raconté oh je suis vraiment confuse
et j'étais ridicule de maître avec ses
ne vous inquiétez pas je me suis
entraîné à donner des poignées de main
molle je ne le ferai plus jamais mal
selon de l'homme
malheureusement il n'en est plus
question pourquoi